oui
les locaux
on est des antiracistes convaincu on est
venu pour dire que tout le monde n'était
pas d'accord et compositions toute façon
pacifique on a des t-shirts que je dois
me retirer pour éviter de me faire à
nouveau cassé la gueule jeux
géniaux j'ignorais ce que je
pensais qu'on était en démocratie qu'on
pouvait donc dire ce qu'on avait à dire
et qu'on n'aurait pas de conséquences
physiques
on est des militants pacifiques
je suis reprise je savais que je m'en
étais des lettres qui faisait la phrase
non au racisme vous allez
on était juste un rang devant nous il y
avait pas mal de mecs qui d'un coup on
se sont déshabillés prandelli tee shirts
cap le racisme tout ça puis d'un coup la
plume ou qui sait par qui ces excités
vachement donc énormément pas foulé en
fait on a cru bon de connaître tous se
faire raser en tout cas notre ange et on
est parti pour les artistes mais
sûrement plus de peur que de mal mais
mais en échange d'un homme et c'était
c'était un groupe de personnes qui s'est
un peu et qui se sont mis sur leur jeu
lâchait ses militants est en fait le pas
du tout il venait juste le bâtard croix
et du coup un bon voilà un peu de plus
de peur que de mal au racing on dit
qu'il ya des choses qui avait volé des
ceintures on n'a rien vu de tout ça non
non on a eu juste cette petite foule
ayant rien
sacré auquel toutes les sécurités
carélie qui ce qui se passe